i wasn't balanced before sure cool sir
we're asking i'm not going nowhere sir
sir no
sir i'm going to say hold two for one
account that's all this is man it's all
good listen
i don't want to throw you out of here
but we're going to now i'm going to
all right come on let's get him get him
out get this summer [ __ ] out get him
out
[ __ ] get out get it get out you son of a
[ __ ]
get out hey you son get out of here
get off my breath
now feel this okay now feel this here
you go
sir please don't hurt my friend
don't hurt him don't hurt him don't hurt
him don't hurt him he's pretty strong
you feel that no i've already gave up i
gave up i gave up
feels good it's also late
i'm too light you know what we're shitty
bouncers
i usually use my sir you can stay here
nice sir you can stay here
sir you can stay here better check on
the bartender sure we just want now we
just want to leave now i'm gonna go
today finally we're at damn near 50 000
subscribers we said every 25 000 we're
gonna fly a fan out so it's long overdue
we randomly pick our boy sheldon and
when i say fly out i mean he took a long
drive from orange county yeah i know
he's from orange county oh it's not a
plane shut up he's here he's working out
with the boys and then he sat down on
the podcast find the kid he met the old
man brian count who also looks like his
dad you guys will find out and we're not
sure we are running a dna test so it
might be brian's son so i don't know if
it was random no i could say this out
loud yep what up boys we are here at zoo
culture for the lift with the fly out
fan there he is sheldon the day has come
flat he drove but it's it's rush hour
you fox it's russia so it's like flying
from london
let's get it
yeah
i'll react if i had to put some things
in the past too and don't let them
distract you but react if you have to
i'll react if i had to put some things
in the past too and don't let them
distract you but react if you have to
react
[Music]
[Applause]
just know that i'm here
[Music]
not anybody in this house
ever since he cut his hair and trimmed
it up he can't live the same way no more
hey oh oh he went to costa rica he could
he can't live the same anymore which is
true but it's still at the same time
he's doing it you know what i'm saying
hold that out haters
is
[Applause]
[Music]
drinking water and eating is probably
not what you're thinking but i
we are here with our first fan sheldon
out from orange county baby real estate
if you need a house this is the boy
we'll tag him in it um so yeah
when did you start following brennan and
how did you get involved with this early
on man i've been going to a shows
started following since day one you know
since he was on the joe rogan podcast
but a big fan of the show king of the
sting firing the kid food truck all the
above man great guy great group of
people
um you know i'm glad i was randomly
selected met some good buddies out here
got some good work in yeah and how was
the day was it was the lift as hard as
you thought it would be it was tough man
i can't front it was hard it was hard
work but i knew that coming in because
uh you know just look at the guys look
at mark harley look at b shop they're
big dudes so i kind of prepped as much
as i could for it um but yeah man the
whole day experience was great got to
sit in on the show uh like you said met
brian callan could be my dad maybe uh
but yeah i was all around good good time
and that's our guy right there thanks
man uh so he's asking for about county
fairs here's the thing when you have
kids and you know i have a five-year-old
and a he'll be too soon when you have
kids dude those county fairs are lit for
them it's like
you for them it's better than disneyland
no you need a county fair that serves
alcohol yes like if that's the key and
the baby
i've been to the one in l.a didn't serve
alcohol and it was a [ __ ] exhausting
[ __ ] walk it was so it basically
turns into a walk into a parking lot of
you just going so when do we get the
[ __ ] we get out of here and then all of
a sudden you're like oh [ __ ] sheep
[ __ ] do look like real [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they do look like just i swear to god
this was
i didn't know that i didn't know that
there's nothing but the sheep they look
i mean if you say have you seen let's
say gabriel she [ __ ] real [ __ ] where
you pull up a sheep [ __ ] or a real
[ __ ] and we gotta guess which one it is
because i'm telling you i could not tell
the difference
i was at a county fair my wife was with
the kids my my wife's husband's there
and and
and so uh
and we go into the barnyard thing and i
see a sheep from behind and i went holy
[ __ ] and leanne goes stop it i go no it
looks she goes please stop it
she's like she's like you please be good
she's like i go man it looks like you
and she's like my dad is right there
sheeps [ __ ] look
have you seen like the zero dark 30
night vision that the seals use when
they zoom in in the middle east and you
just see some dude just [ __ ] a sheep
and they're like all clowning them and
laughing and [ __ ] god [ __ ] sheep like
here's the thing
if how crazy it would be if they were
like if they were like president obama
was just like hey just so you know
new mass mandate also you can [ __ ] sheep
it's not cheating and it's not
bestiality it's all good and it's all
good house
sheep sales are through the [ __ ] roof
no one's eating uh asabuko at all
nothing i don't even know if that is
that lamb i don't even know [ __ ]
sometimes i say words i don't know what
they mean
but that's my entire career for august
i'm in north carolina was that the 19th
and 21st first north carolina august
19th through the 21st and then la jolla
comedy store end of the month uh that's
a thursday friday saturday the last
month of august i'm at la jolla comedy
store tickets at thickboy.com or
f-a-t-k-z.com
bert i [ __ ] love you dude i love you
too bro
thank you for having me
we're here with the old birdie boy you
want to see some of this
yeah see if there's any fuzz in that
navel oh [ __ ] that's one of the things i
have to do before i shoot a special is
i've checked to make sure my necklace is
straight and there's no fuzz in my navel
and then my belt straight what's up
everybody shout out to thick boy nation
[ __ ] bernie shobb doing it right
in [ __ ] where's his where's his new
studio calabasas god damn it
[ __ ] theo slipped up you should have
never moved to nashville yeah we're
right down the street from the
kardashians are you really probably
they're probably around there oh
i can't wait is there gonna be a fight
companion yeah can you put me on one
[ __ ] fight companion
thick boy studios i am getting [ __ ]
wasted and talking trash like i can
fight i can't wait
too many
what we got going on tonight you know
just the second calves fight campaign
with the squad
lebron ortega tj dillashaw
josh thompson and mark carley
[Music]
drinking some good whiskey
watching fights hanging out with friends
can't really beat it
what's your next move
i know we got recovery coming up next
move for me is yeah
i mean three month recovery for knee
surgery
is that knee surgery for my last fight
after that fight for the world title
beginning next year get my belt back
he's gonna have that off and a belt on
next time you see him yeah proves i'm
the world's best spammingway of all time
and uh
who knows walk off since sunset have a
good time that's a wrap man thank you
for coming out